let's talk about these cartridges that
is lying around on the bus yeah which
ones are those okay look we got a couple
64 cartridges here we got Mario Kart 2
or no I'm sorry are you partying it
oh it's Mario Party barn party why are
you a card somewhere right here and then
of course but this is the real classic
yes gem all day we got this Goldeneye
this is this might be top this is
definitely top 10 games of all time
without a dime might be top 5 this is
like [__] insane so you have a 64 on
the bus got a 64 on the bus yeah I had a
[__] Xbox one and it's a shitty
sister dog yeah don't buy Xbox one and
I'm sorry Xbox but [__] X but if you
would like to send him a couple free
ones no I may have a buck Xbox team
PlayStation all day I already got my ps4
but if you already send me some new ones
that's cool
anyway the reason I don't [__] Xbox
dog I'm on the same level
yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry and I usually
don't talk [__] about nothing
[__] Xbox such a nice guy you see I see
fashion yeah [__] Xbox because I spent
seven hours on the Xbox all the game all
the new games and a [__] everything
and I've ran on a tour bus and that [__]
you got to download like gigs and gigs
and gigs off the internet and it's like
yeah the tour bus Wi-Fi is pretty good
and then good is not good enough to be
downloading a [__] game yeah dog when
I buy some [__] I want to [__] play
right then in there I agree
Thank You PlayStation now what is a if
you off the top of your head cuz I know
you're a gamer can you give us like a
rough top five games of all time easily
The Last of Us have you played that [__]
hi oh yes no ps3 oh yeah that's a new
one yeah that's not incredible I agree
Last of Us Metal Gear Solid yes
originally the first one where you had
to switch where you had to switch
controller ports to fight Psycho Mantis
duh yeah when I was a kid I was so lost
about how to beat Psycho Mantis no but
on my dad's drug dealer came over I
already had the game you got a switch
controller for Pete the edge bunny is
she that one uncharted I don't know in
charge great Mike yeah it is crazy uh
BioShock Infinite the newest when it
came out I never got it I played the
first virus I was in about hockey time I
really like those other ones
okay one is amazing it's incredible that
[__] is that's what give us one more it
was like something pre ps3 oh why you
already gave us Metal Gear Solid um
Borderlands I [__] with that too and I
haven't I had Borderlands 2 and call of
duty modern warfare 2 that's my favorite
one my girlfriend she's my sheep I'm a
battlefield guy yeah but nah me too
because I got GG bathroom for course it
was amazing no one liked the opening
scene yes all the OBE is and you're like
in the car what I love about battlefield
is all the duty is hard it's hard to be
a sniper in ecology because the maps
aren't that big yes your battlefield you
could Schneider [__] from the
other side of the [__] it's yo do you
know why I [__] love Blake it because
every time me and him talk we either
talk about video games and porn stars
form [__] not me the cool thing about
this is the cool thing about this is is
like it really gives my fans
opportunities just like talk about like
normal a normal guy okay I'm like we
don't always have to talk about the
hip-hop [__] we like the hip-hop [__]
yeah yeah I don't have a stripper pole
on the tour bus or anything odd video
games
he's got video games yeah hundred
percent